un profesional médico puede medir su
presión arterial para saber si tiene
presión arterial alta este vídeo le
ayudará a comprender qué significan los
números en la presión arterial
se puede medir la presión arterial con
un dispositivo para la presión arterial
denominado stic manómetro
cuando el corazón late la presión de la
sangre en las paredes de las arterias se
denomina presión sistólica
cuando su corazón se relaja entre
latidos la presión en la pared arterial
es llamada presión diastólica
su tensión arterial puede cambiar a lo
largo del día sin embargo la tensión
sistólica óptima debería ser inferior a
120 y la tensión diastólica óptima
debería ser inferior a 80
si su tensión sistólica con frecuencia
se mantiene por encima de 130 o su
tensión diastólica con frecuencia se
mantiene por encima de 80 usted sufre de
tensión arterial alta
sus objetivos específicos pueden variar
dependiendo de la situación de su salud
pregúntele a su médico cuáles deben ser
los objetivos de su presión arterial